the conclusion to regulation in the afc
championship game saw tom brady throw a
bad pass rob gronkowski started a chance
to catch it pops into the air
chiefs intercept but all d ford offside
and that kept the drive alive patriots
take the lead chiefs tie it up they go
to overtime and the patriots win what if
wednesday we we go back to that play
what if d4 isn't offside sharing what if
that interception counts and the chiefs
have the ball at that point
at their own 36 with 54 seconds left and
the patriots have three timeouts how
does that game play out from that point
forward and do we see chiefs rams in the
super bowl
you know i don't know who came up with
this what if but it is a great what if
because so many things would have
changed starting with i think we all
believe the kansas city chiefs would
have won that football game
would we look at the patriots
i do think we see the chiefs as super
bowl champions at this point i do think
they win the super bowl i think bob
sutton's still there i think d ford's
still there i think frank clark is not
in kansas city he's somewhere else so
many things to me change if d ford stays
on side doesn't line up offsides i just
think it was a huge play that we're
going to remember for a really long time
especially the people in kansas city are
going to remember this for a really long
time they win it this year i guess it
gets forgotten a little bit a little
footnote but if they don't i think we're
going to go back and point to this play
for a really really long time that it
changed the fortunes of the kansas city
chiefs and maybe changed the fortunes of
the patriots a little bit would rob
gronkowski still be uh playing for the
new england patriots today
well and i
look i
i've learned the hard way over the years
what happens when you doubt the new
england patriots and bill belichick and
he had all three timeouts no questions
54 seconds left that the chiefs would
have had the ball on their own 36. andy
reid presumably runs the ball three
times although who knows maybe he
decides to throw caution to the wind and
have patrick mahomes throw a pass and
maybe bill belichick's got something
dialed up where they intercept and they
get a short field but i i think tom
brady would have had a chance now what
would there have been left maybe 35
seconds 40 seconds to get down the field
but i'm not ready to rule out the
patriots pulling this one out they
wouldn't have needed overtime to do it
they would have scored a touchdown and
walked off 31-28 winners if they would
have gotten the ball back and if they
would have gotten down the field but i
think it's more likely the chiefs would
have won and in that moment i think we
all thought oh there it goes that there
went the patriots and here go the chiefs
and you're right the chiefs wouldn't
have had maybe the sweeping changes that
we saw defensively ford would still be
there most likely sutton would be there
now i'm curious about why you think the
chiefs would have won the super bowl
because we saw that rams chiefs game
in late november the epic 5451 back and
forth rams win the game why do you think
it would have been different the second
time around
well i'm basing it obviously on what we
saw the rams do in the postseason now we
know the chiefs defense was just flat
out awful i think they were 31st in the
nfl last season in total defense which
is why they made all those changes
but just based on the way the rams
played in that super bowl especially
offensively and you know it was that all
those practices as a pool reporter with
the rams and to me offensively they just
didn't look that good in practice either
i just don't think they were going to
score a lot of points even if it was
against that chief's defense and with
todd gurley obviously not being a big
part of that offense i just don't think
they would have scored enough points to
keep up with the chiefs in that football
game
i think back to the comments from sean
mcveigh the coach of the rams from a
couple of weeks ago where he said he
kind of outsmarted himself he didn't
work as smart as he could have he spent
too much time on other things in that
dead week and and you know maybe it's
different if you're not freaked out by
bill belichick and i think that that
belichick angle may have crept into his
brain a little bit and affected his
preparation whereas if you're going
against andy reid you beat him in the
regular season you don't have that same
trepidation that maybe you would but uh
i'm not i'm not ready to say the
patriots would have lost the afc
championship game and i'm definitely not
ready to say the rams wouldn't won the
super bowl although the big difference
is todd gurley wasn't the same guy by
the end of the year that he was during
that game although he did he didn't do a
ton in that in that rams chiefs game if
i remember correctly but he definitely
wasn't the same guy at the end of the
year and that still lingers into this
season i you know we i think we've
exhausted the what if
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports